[Música]
hola a todos bueno muchísimas gracias
por estar aquí hoy yo os quiero decir
que hoy es un día súper especial para mí
porque además de estar entre todos
vosotros además de estar aquí he
conseguido algo que para mí es muy
importante y es que mi padre está aquí
hoy conmigo es un gallego muy especial
porque es un gallego como tantos otros
súper resiliente que al fallecer su
padre mi abuelo con siete años se tuvo
que marchar de galicia y fue casi desde
el principio un súper empresario o por
lo menos lo fue para mí porque somos
cuatro hermanos así que bueno te quiero
dar las gracias antes de nada gracias
pero bueno no solo yo tengo suerte no
solo yo tengo suerte creo que todos
nosotros tenemos suerte porque vivimos
una época muy especial y de cómo
aprovechar esas oportunidades desde lo
que quiero hablar hoy estamos en una
época de muchísimos cambios estamos en
una época que no solo tiene cambios sino
que es un cambio de época estamos en una
época donde
pasa algo distinto a lo que ha pasado
con anterioridad la verdad es que
estamos en un momento donde podemos ser
y esto sí que es un gran cambio
protagonistas de esta historia podemos
ser actores principales en esta historia
podemos ser los colom del siglo 21 y
esto es algo que creo que muy poquita
gente ha tenido oportunidad de hacer a
lo largo de la historia y estamos aquí
hoy cómo aprovechar estas oportunidades
pues bueno ya ha comentado josé ramón yo
soy empresario y creo que una de las
maneras más inteligentes es ir por la
vida pues eso con gafas de empresario
con gafas de buscar oportunidades con
gafas o con ojos de ver los huecos de
ver qué se puede hacer estamos en un
mundo maravilloso y tenemos que ir con
esos esos ojazos abiertos por el mundo
claro dentro de lo que se puede hacer
hay muchísimas opciones y para eso pues
yo en mi caso voy al maestro mi padre
hace 50 años monté una empresa en el
sector textil en él
una sastrería y le fue razonablemente
bien yo hace 20 monté una en tecnología
y lo curioso o lo singular de esto es
que buscamos sectores muy distintos pero
que en su momento eran iguales y es que
éramos sectores que estaban en
crecimiento eran cosas que iban hacia
arriba una de las enseñanzas básicas es
que las cosas que hagas en sectores que
van hacia arriba es mucho más fácil que
tengan éxito o sea si uno se dedica
ahora a temas de fútbol seguro que le va
a ir bien es un momento para buscar ese
tipo de oportunidades pero claro
no solo esos ojos buscando oportunidades
los tenemos nosotros los tiene más gente
entonces sí que es verdad que hay que
hacer las cosas un poquito distintas hay
que intentar evolucionar eso cuántas
veces nos han dicho esto de adaptarnos
mi padre y vuelvo a él y perdonadme pero
tengo una oportunidad muy buena para
hacérselo se adaptó cambiando la
sastrería por la peletería estamos en
galicia la peletería es un sector muy
muy importante más fino mejor pagado y
bueno nos fue o les fue durante
muchísimos años bien yo cambié o adapte
la formación informática a la
informática por la industria la
impresión 3d las robots los drones y
está yendo también razonablemente bien
entonces eso es importante busquemos
sectores que estén hacia arriba sectores
que estén innovando pero ojo estamos con
un momento ahora tan distinto donde en
la época de mi padre colaborar cooperar
hacer las cosas con otros aprender de
otros era realmente complicado estaba
reservado a privilegiados hoy no lo
hemos tenido o tenemos la suerte de
tener a jose luis cordero aquí delante y
con un clic y ni siquiera con un clic
sino escuchando le tenemos
eminencia a la que podemos o de la que
podemos aprender esto es algo por lo que
yo creo que nosotros tenemos suerte el
poder aprender de la gente buena de la
gente super top y los buenos nunca lo
son por casualidad siempre lo son por
causalidad es decir siempre son
consecuencia de algo la gente que es
realmente buena lo es por algo y cuando
estás con ellos un rato pues te das
cuenta estamos en un momento donde eso
es fácil claro que podemos copiar les
podemos aprender de ellos pero creo que
también es importante que mantengamos
nuestra propia luz es decir tener la
capacidad de mirarnos un poco dentro de
buscarnos de preguntar o de preguntarnos
a los nuestros si eso encaja con lo que
hacemos es muy importante alinear lo que
hacemos con lo que somos y para eso hay
que pararse un poquito también y aunque
los buenos son muy buenos también
nosotros tenemos que tener nuestro
huequecito de aquí me sale una reflexión
deseo una carta a los reyes y es que
bueno todos nosotros desde hoy seamos
capaces de ver oportunidades de hacer
cosas hacer cosas distintas hacer cosas
con muchísima gente de sectores
distintos
función que os vaya bien yo además de
desearon suerte creo que tengo un
poquito más de suerte porque para mí eso
de ir aprovechando las oportunidades y
de mirar a los míos hoy lo tengo muy muy
fácil porque no tengo más que salir a la
calle en galicia en mi tierra me meto en
una taberna pido un poquito de ribeira
un poquito de pulpo me siento con mi
padre y nos ponemos a hablar muchísimas
gracias a todos
[Aplausos]